the test scores that people have on sats
and gmats is directly proportional the
number of problems they solved before
taking the test so it's a very clear
input output equation I love those types
of equations I bought every single GMAT
phone book that I could find at Barnes
and Nobles and I did all of them I
bought eight books it was about this
much and I did every single problem all
of the books and that's how I scored
above Harvard's GMAT mid score and it
took me four months to do that and so I
worked personally four hours a day doing
problems and then on Saturday I would do
a test to test my score to see if I got
better and what ended up happening near
the end I would start reading the
questions because there's only so many
ways that they can ask the question and
so you probably have about a hundred
different problem sets in your head
where they just changed the names and
the numbers but the way you solve it is
the same yes you just need enough
exposure to that that you can
predictably get your scores up